hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
on my website movie universe be calm
thanks and enjoy the video alright so in
this video we're going to talk about
glycerophospholipids specifically as a
subset of membrane lipids so previously
we discussed how the general structure
of a glycerophospholipid has the
glycerol backbone - two fatty acid tails
and the polar head group being the
phosphate group attached to some alcohol
portion so what does that actually look
like in terms of the atoms so well let's
draw the glycerol backbone here glycerol
backbone so this is the glycerol
backbone color core color coded right
it's in blue just like it is over here
that's the glycerol backbone and these
oxygens here are going to be the linkage
points to the fatty acids up here and
the polar head group down here so we've
got a fatty acid up here an acyl chain
right and we've got another acyl chain
here and of course these are groups on
these fatty fatty acid chains or these
acyl groups can be different so this
first one actually is usually a
saturated fatty acid and the second one
here is usually an unsaturated fatty
acid and these which saturated fatty
acid or which unsaturated fatty acid
these things are can vary between
organisms and it can actually even vary
between organs or tissues within an
organism okay so now for the polar head
group we've got the phosphate group
right here and then right next to that
is the alcohol now the alcohol is is is
of course part of the the polar head
polar head groups of Scituate right now
that part is what can vary alright I
mean obviously we talked about these
fatty acids can vary too but that's not
really what I'm going to look at mostly
I'm looking mostly what's going on the
polar head group
because I think about this and I think
about how the the phosphate group here
has a negative charge this thing has a
negative charge right there and this
this polar head groups of situate the
content that contains this alcohol this
alcohol can vary which alcohol it is can
vary so this alcohol may or may not
carry a charge and if it does have a
charge it can be positive or negative so
there's ambiguity here what kind of
charge is this the idea though is that
we're gonna have this negative charge
over here in this phosphate group and
we're gonna have we could have some
charge or no charge here at from the
alcohol but that's going to equal some
total charge and this can vary right
this could end up being positive this
could be negative overall or it could be
neutral overall the idea though is that
you can have some sort of charge or no
charge and that can vary depending on
the the identity of this alcohol
attached here so that's important
because you could have different
possibilities different charges and that
would ultimately lead to different
properties from one glycerophospholipid
to the next now the question is an
important question is what is the
simplest x substituent well the simplest
thing that you can have is just a
hydrogen attached right if this X was
just hydrogen that particular
glycerophospholipid would be named
phosphatidic acid phosphatidic acid okay
and that is the parent compound of when
it comes to glycerophospholipids all the
other names are based on this idea
phosphatidic acid so what would be the
overall charge in phosphatidic acid well
the hydrogen doesn't carry a charge
right it's just going to be attached
there so the only charge is coming from
the phosphate group which would be
negative so it would be negative one so
let's think about some other examples of
glycerophospholipids so basically we
just talked about how it's going to be
based on what is the identity of VX
substitute
what is the alcohol that is coming from
these are some common
glycerophospholipids basically if you
take the X and replace it with this
group here this group is uh has these
two carbons right it's 2 CH 2 and then
this amine group here and this is coming
from an alcohol if we imagine the
alcohol if we imagine an OHA over here
right then this molecule would be called
ethanolamine
okay and so what that would be named in
the visceral phospholipid it'd be named
based off the phosphatidic acid right so
we call a phosphatidyl and then we
follow up with the alcohol named ethanol
amine so the glycerophospholipid that
contains this X group would be called
phosphatidyl ethanolamine so the next
one here I don't know if you baby you
can quiz yourself if you recognize this
structure but this structure it's coming
from the alcohol named choline so if you
drew an O H out here that would be
choline right so the name of the quiz
real phospholipid would be phosphatidyl
choline down here this should be really
recognizable if I drew a no H out here
should be you should recognize it very
easily that is an amino acid and it is
specifically serine so you might might
have already guessed it this would be
phosphatidyl serine so these are common
glycerophospholipids this last one down
here is actually pretty important if we
threw an LH up there now bear in mind in
all these cases the LH isn't actually
there right it's just the this bond is
the connection point to the phosphate
group on the glycerophospholipid but I'm
just drawing these OHS here to indicate
that these things come from alcohols
with these names so this one here comes
from myo-inositol four or five
bisphosphate so equatorial phospholipid
name would be phosphatidyl inositol for
five bits phosphate otherwise known as
pip2 and you might have seen that before
fib 2 is important in the ip3
daj signaling pathway so in signal
transduction tip 2 is actually cleaved
into I B 3 and D AG which are the two
second messengers in that signaling
pathway so that's an example of a
certain location where a
glycerophospholipid is important and
specifically important in a signaling
pathway I hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching yo if you found
that video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe for more content and
if you know anybody who might find the
video is helpful then please share it
with them
thanks happy studying